atusa welcome uh to the show
congratulations for a very important
Victory against the defending champion
this is your first US chess
championships as well how does it feel
to be uh playing in your first US Chess
Championship um hi guys
so actually um this tournament is a
little bit uh new for me compared to the
other players so I just tried to be
solid but uh I drew my first two games
and I lost yesterday which I didn't
expect it but anyway uh so uh yeah I
mean it's a great way to come back after
loss with a victory against the
champion yes exactly I mean um Jennifer
is a strong player and uh uh I'm happy
that I could win today tell us a bit
about the the game when did you feel
like you're taking over the
initiative uh actually I expected her to
play this line so I was uh prepared for
this line and I thought that I mean
throughout the game uh White was more
comfortable I'm not sure about uh my
queen A4 Queen D1 idea but I knew that
even after exchanging the pawns still I
have uh passed on on A3 so that should
be fine that's the key and uh yeah
exactly and um I mean her position was
more difficult to defend than mine so my
my position was I think more comfortable
definitely agree uh with that assessment
and it was at this point when she took a
pawn but you finally managed to get your
Pawn all the way to A7 and now it's
starting to look pretty clear that not
only you have enough compensation for
your lost Pawn but in fact you're just
simply breaking through you're winning
at this point and you conducted the
attack very nicely Queen to A4 invade
via D7 and then this queen sacrifice
atusa congratulations great game
tomorrow is the rest day what what are
your plans for the rest
day uh actually I think I'm going to
just rest a little bit because even
though we played just four games but it
feels more more than that and also we're
going to go to one of the schools high
school here and I'm looking forward to
it because this is my first time
excellent congratulations atusa we'll
see you in a couple of days enjoy enjoy
the lessons uh that uh we do in the
community